[Musique]
mouais ya un gars qui vient d'appeler un
docteur cherche un chauffeur ça
t'intéresse je ne suis pas docteur en
médecine
je suis musicien je suis sur le point de
partir en tournée dans le sud profond
quel genre d'expérience avez-vous
les relations publiques verriez-vous un
inconvénient à travailler pour un noir
vous dans le sud
ça va causer des problèmes
premiers mois tu écriras c'est promis et
pas que ça sent pas bon ce n'est jamais
avalé de tous les frais de toute mon
existence mais le gens comme vous adore
la poule est frais il avait une vision
de moi plutôt étriqué de tenir je sais
soit main
nous allons fréquenter les personnes les
plus riches du pays alors je pense que
vos manières gagnerait à être plus
raffinée mais pourquoi vous les voyez
menu parce que vous valez mieux que ça
monsieur vallée longue j'ai vu docteur
shirley jouer du piano
c'est un génie je crois aller manger un
bout je préfère ne pas mettre de gras
sur ma tenue où je veux pas mais de
grâce sur ma tenue
ce monsieur dit que je ne peux patiner
ici j'ai bien peur que non
[Musique]
comment il fait pour rester aussi
aimable il faut du courage pour changer
le coeur des joues
qu'est ce que vous faites une lettre je
peux voir cher de l'aurès des fois tu me
rappelles la maison vous êtes conscient
que c'est lamentable sonné note la
distance qui nous sépare des vastes mon
âme
tombé amoureux de toi a été la chose la
plus facile du monde
s embrassent l'everest c'est comme
klaxonner à la fin de la septième de
chostakovitch et c'est bien parfaitement
bien de sauter la voiture on ne gagne
jamais grâce à la violence pour ne gagne
qu en garde dans sa dignité
pourquoi laisser parler votre goût
monsieur je me la pète tu fais des
concerts pour les rupins si je suis
passé noir mais aussi pas assez blanc
alors je suis quoi dites le moi
au monde peut faire de beethoven
[Musique]
et votre musique puisque vous faites
vous
et avoue qu'il pouvait faire
que fait-on avec les restes ont fait ça
ramassez tony les écureuils le bouffon
toute façon ramasser
[Musique]